foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by best-selling author of the book
from paycheck to purpose Mr Ken Coleman
and we are taking your calls this hour
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five and this is the show all about
breakthrough all about Hope and so if
you need that in any area of your life
especially money and career we are your
guys today yeah so when we say career
that's a big broad statement so let's
break it down into work related
questions maybe you got a toxic boss or
a leader and you're feeling miserable
burned out but you're in the baby steps
you feel like I have no choices I can't
I can't move on yes you can we'll help
you through some of those type of work
related questions hey Ken I want to get
a promotion I want to make more money is
it possible
um I'm gonna okay job but I'm not sure
what I'd love to do so those those are
some contexts that are real that we
handle on the Ken Coleman show and we'll
take on those today and they all have
money components oh yeah and George and
I love being together uh we are a
listener uh listener labeled us as the
root beer I just got a message it makes
a one listener giggle every time they
hear it so there you go so we're here to
please just an audience of one today and
we've done that so now we're ready I
think for phone calls but you jump in
we'll talk about your life your money
your work triple eight eight two five
five two two five Christine kicks us off
in Dallas Texas Christine welcome to the
show
thanks for having me yeah what's going
on
so um I'm on baby step number two and my
question is my largest debt has a
judgment against me and they recently
sent me another letter saying that
they're looking for post-judgment
Discovery requests and I have 30 days to
produce
um about six days away from that and I
guess my biggest question is while I
have other smaller debts that I was
trying to tackle what is your advice for
navigating the settlement when the debt
is so high what's the details of this
how how big is the debt and how much
money do you have and what's been the
latest communication
okay
um so I have I owe twenty two thousand
dollars roughly and
um when I called them they told me they
would take eighteen thousand
um they asked me how much money I had
saved and I do have five thousand
dollars and they told me I could put
that down and then be on a payment plan
for 12 months
to pay off the rest to get it to 18.
okay and so it would add up to 18 over
the following after you give them the
thousand
yes after I get a no after I give them
the five thousand oh you have five then
yes I have five thousand you know not
including my emergency thousand dollars
okay so so that means that you now owe
them 13 or that was the remaining amount
that had to be paid off in 12 months
yes okay and you're six days away how
much have you paid
away from just having to turn in all of
statements and all the different things
they want to make sure you know actually
you're not sitting on 50 Grand I'm sorry
okay okay yeah okay so your question is
how do you navigate this while in baby
step two you have other debts to deal
with
I have yeah I have another one that I
was just speaking with as well um that
one is ninety six hundred dollars they
told me they would take 2 800 which is
roughly about 30 of what I owe
um
so now I'm kind of stuck because yeah
they're not they don't have a judgment
against me but it is in collection so I
was just trying to tackle all my small
ones but then the biggest one comes at
me with the Judgment so yeah I would I
would tackle all of the debts that are
in collections all the ones you're
behind on tackle those first because
those are going to be the ankle biters
uh holding you back and if you can make
minimum payments on the rest of your
debts or that you're current on are you
able to do that
yes okay so let's are these the only two
that are in collections are there more
right these are the only two that are in
collections um I'm fine everywhere else
I have one car payment
um that's about it okay so let's you're
on the payment plan for the largest debt
you're going to settle with the next
well on a payment plan yet that's I
guess what I was going to ask you
because they want to put me on one but
everything I've read says to try to do
the lump sum but I know I can't pay 18
000 off have you talked to them about
doing a lump sum
later on I did and they still said 18.
which is a which is a break from the 25
that you owe them
right but they're not going to wait 12
months to get the 18. that's what you're
saying
Well they um I was trying to see where I
could get with a lump sum and they said
um I'm a curing interest every day of
311 or 3.11 cents every day since the
Judgment
um they said they would waive the
um
that feed you know they would waive the
um
those fees and take 20 or take 18. okay
and are you needing to give them access
to your account for this or can you
write them a cashier's check or money
order every month
they said I could make a payment each
month
um and if I miss one payment then it
goes all the way back to what I owe
what's the language of the Judgment
George I'm a little naive on this
particular well you say judgment
does that mean a judge is involved
no um they sent me something and they
said you know that they were they went
to the county where I live and they did
file a lawsuit I was actually having a
baby when the hearing was but I did
respond I responded and I said this is
the first I've heard of this you know
going to court can you please give me
some more information so I wanted to
make sure it was legit and all of a
sudden all I got was a letter from the
county that said here's the date of your
hearing and I wasn't able to physically
go I was in the hospital and then I got
a letter that said that they were
granted
um this judgment on me and then I didn't
hear from them at all until at the end
towards the end of September
um I got this that said that they're
looking for
um more information so that they can see
you know how much money I have and they
do say at the end that they would like
to resolve this matter amicably to
contact them and so that's when I did
call the law firm nothing sounds
amicable like you just got sued in court
let's do this yeah yeah well I mean if
the county has has the judgment against
you we now have to deal with with that
situation so I would put that on the top
of your list of things to deal with
followed by the settlement and let the
other collector know Hey listen I'm
dealing with this right now as soon as
I'm done my next goal is to settle with
you for that 30 amount here's what I'm
going to be able to do that and so as
long as you're in very clear constant
communication uh we're going to get rid
of the the collections monkeys off your
back and then we're going to focus on
the rest of your debts how many other
debts do you have What's the total
amount
um I have just um
let's cut that up today can we please
cut that up today Christine
yeah it's a rubber crutch
and it's part of the reason we're in
this hole is because we thought well the
credit card companies are they're going
to be my savior they're going to be my
emergency fund yeah and as we're
realizing debt is not a friend it's not
a tool and so I think as a as a moment
where you go I'm going to draw a line in
the sand never again I've had it we're
going to cut up this car today and it's
not going to become well I'm going to
keep it open on paid I'm not let's just
cut it up be done with it use your debit
card do you have one of those
yeah I do okay great what's your income
it's actually just got a new job and
it's 127 000. let's go Christine so how
quickly we're gonna clean up this mess
how many months
[Music]
how many months am I going to take to
clean up the mess yeah to get rid of
debt completely
uh I would say about a year there we go
a year from now you're gonna be looking
back on this Christine going that was
the moment when collectors were calling
me I'm in the hospital while getting
sued debt is not my friend I'm gonna
become the bank never again is someone
gonna tell me how I'm gonna live my life
we are rooting for you Christine wishing
you the best on this debt-free journey
give us a call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
it's your show give us a call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your money your work all of it I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour and we just took a
heart-wrenching call yep woman who's got
a judgment against her for a bunch of
credit card debt and still got the card
open
trying to pay it off every month and it
just it got me thinking again you know
there's a lot of slick marketing out
there from the credit card companies and
a lot of ads as we uh watch YouTube
videos and so I saw this one
from Credit Karma so we wanted to play
it for you and get your live reaction
Ken oh this is very he's never seen this
never seen it let's roll this Credit
Karma all right here we go
what are you doing applying for a credit
card on Credit Karma they had this thing
called the karma guarantee it's sort of
like a card fairy wow
apply for a credit card that has the
karma guarantee and you don't get
approved the card Ferry will slip 50
bucks under your pillow is he coming
tonight nope
just got approved the card Fair will
just have to rummage around in someone
else's fridge get approved or get 50
bucks on offers with the karma guarantee
ah how heartwarming wow it's so precious
we have the little the little cute
little girl the little Angelic voice
what you do he did the creepy wizard man
and so the whole thing is like like you
know like someone's gonna come save you
you know and I love the idea that if you
don't if you don't get approved for one
of these credit card offers because that
would mean you're in such bad financial
shape even credit card companies are
going nope yeah then Credit Karma will
give you 50 bucks right put it under
your pillow yeah that's the thing that
was sickening and and I gotta tell you
the other thing that it does the thing
that really bothers me is they're
playing to kids kids are in the room
while Mom and Dad are watching TV and
what's really Insidious about this is
and I mean Insidious is that they're
they're normalizing credit and credit
card words to little kids who don't even
have the foggiest idea what it really
means that's what's really and I'm
telling you I I can see it right now
that their ad marketing agencies that do
all this stuff for these companies
they're sitting in there going okay we
have a couple things we want to
accomplish here right and and and and
don't think for a second that the credit
karma executive said Hey try to make it
this and let's kind of I mean they are
pounding this into very intentional it's
very intentional to create normalcy
remember folks marketing is all about
removing your objections to anything
right it's why like we're sitting there
watching sports the other night with my
boys watch the football game commercials
come on
and first thing it's one of these
pharmaceutical companies same tactics
do you have dry mouth sore neck and
itchy feet I'm going well I got two of
the three what's wrong with me you know
two out of the same pads there's nothing
wrong with me but it's like that it's a
normalizing of activity and normalizing
of symptoms
normalizing drugs normalizing debt I
gotta Tell You Folks
um these people are very talented well
and I'll tell you it's a game and you
are in The Matrix and until you wake up
you're going to be susceptible for this
I got to tell you shame on that that
that is so ridiculous it drives me nuts
and here's how this works Ken because
Credit Karma is partnering with all
these credit card companies and so
they're offering up discover and
American Express and all these different
offerings and they get Kickbacks if you
sign up and so they must be making buku
bucks if they're just throwing out fifty
dollar bills for anyone that gets denied
not to mention the ad development and
the ad by now let's just go to where we
are real time all right George let's go
to reality again in my hands right here
a CBS News article here's where we stand
and why Credit Karma is thriving
the average credit card rate in the U.S
is now more than 22 percent it's the
highest since 2019 this is according to
Lending Tree data for people who carry a
balance the average rate is 18.4 percent
according to the Federal Reserve and so
with inflation you know tightening
people's everyday activities instead of
reducing expenses increasing
responsibility more discipline what do
people do well inflation's more than my
pay raise so I gotta use a credit card
you sound just like them Ken that was an
amazing impression well no that's
actually the inner character what was
that Disney movie that it was like a
thing that had all these little emotions
and they became like characters that's
what that that's what that emotion
inside thank you James on top of it
because he's got the littles at home he
knows uh but that's that same sniveling
victim type personality I think that's
what they sound like yeah is that inner
voice the headline of this article is
inflation slammed Americans are piling
on credit card debt it goes on to say
steering inflation is driving Americans
to make more purchases on their credit
cards leading them to amass more debt
that is becoming costlier as the FED
hikes interest rates all right so you
know what the number is George hit me
887
billion dollars in credit cards taking
my breath away that's up 13 from a year
ago go
wow
well we hear about the student loan
crisis and the number you hear is 1.7
trillion which means we are halfway
there in credit card debt alone
nearly six in ten Americans who earn
less than 50 000 a year carry a credit
card balance from month to month but
can't everyone I talk to says well I pay
it off every month Ken what's wrong with
hanging on to my credit card I'll pay it
off that's a very good question George
you have no margin
all right so you start looking at I was
looking at some data today uh I was
talking about I was reacting to a viral
Tick Tock video on the Ken Coleman show
and where a tick talker went out there
and said look if you make 25 an hour or
less you ought to be terrified as if
life is over okay now I want people to
make more than 25 an hour in fact I
commit my entire professional life to
you can make way more than that here's
how I want you to make more however it
was so Doom and Gloom so I looked into
the numbers he had this spreadsheet
basically showing that a person who
makes 25 an hour
can barely make ends meet in today's
America well
what's on the spreadsheet the bunch of
debt the car payments and he had 400 as
the average car payment you and I both
know it's actually 667. for seven cars
it's 519 for used cars I looked it up
today and I also looked up that the
median income right now in America uh
per week
um is is just over a thousand dollars a
week so what happens is you do have a
lot of people who are really squeezed
but they're squeezed not just from
income but they're really squeezed by
expenses because all of a sudden if you
take out that 500 600 700 car payment by
the way that's the average
we saw a tick tock recently I think
James showed it to us
where people were like gleefully
bragging on these tick tocks I have a
car payment of twelve hundred dollars
they're all work for car dealerships
they work for car dealerships and it's
like it's mind-numbing George well and
it goes back to this whole thing that
we've normalized all of this through
marketing it's all around you everyone
you know has has payments that's right
it's in every commercial well it starts
with this little girl hey Daddy I'm
gonna have a thousand dollar car payment
one day and it's just Insanity it's like
the Pied Piper leading people off the
cliff I mean was what are we doing here
well this it does start with do you want
more voices George all of them you could
do a one-man show at this point on
Broadway all right so here's what this
turns into you mentioned it Ken but yes
you can make more income an income can
be an issue but we have villainized
every company for not paying us enough
all the while we're throwing thousands
of dollars a month to lenders we're not
doing a good job
the answer is not pay me more and I'm
also for you make it more the answer is
what are we doing with what we have yes
and the truth is when you look down you
go oh it's all going to lenders who are
building really big buildings and
sponsoring every stadium in North
America today that's the truth so how
about we leave our own legacy and put
our own names on some buildings and get
out of debt once and for all these
credit card companies are not your
friend debt is not a tool and the truth
is credit cards have become the
cigarette of the financial world
we all used to think it was cool and now
we know too much and here we are in 887
billion dollar billion dollars of credit
card debt going I don't understand how
we got here I thought the credit card
company's my friend I go on free
vacations Ken yeah I get my points yeah
I'm beating the system no no because
life happens
and you don't have an emergency fund and
you're not hitting your financial goals
and so what do we do we turn to the
credit cards to be our savior and then
they uh they transform Ken before our
eyes into a devil instead of the Angel
you know I gotta tell you you know for
all of the wokism and all of the people
outraged by the bad people of society
it's high time the American people the
average person whether you're
conservative Progressive liberal or
whatever wake up and go the actual bad
guys are the credit card companies it's
predatory lending is what it is take
that American Express if you're
listening you've been outed discover if
you're listening Capital One what's in
your wallet money that's what I want to
be in your wallet not a freaking Capital
One card this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsay personality George Campbell
joined by my colleague Ken Coleman this
hour open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Felicia joins
us up next in Grand Rapids Michigan
Felicia welcome to the show
hi George and Ken thanks for taking my
call absolutely how can we help
yeah I have two really quick questions
to have uh we just started Financial
Peace University we just finished lesson
three awesome um so we're on baby step
one and we're halfway through that and I
realize that we have an upcoming debt uh
credit card bill that was same as cash
because my dog had emergency surgery
um a couple months ago and that due date
is coming up soon in about four weeks so
we were wondering should we go ahead and
pay that so we don't get the interest or
should we just continue funding our
emergency fund and then put that into a
snowball well how much do you have in
the bank right now
[Music]
how quickly can you get the other 500.
um probably
a week or two okay and then what is this
uh the debt the same as cash credit card
debt how much uh it is uh 1200.
okay and it's due in four weeks so the
question is can we scrape together that
kind of money in four weeks can you guys
do side jobs side Hustle sell stuff
um I think so
there's only one answer here and it's
EDS we will do whatever it takes to get
out of this because what's going to
happen and you know this now because you
read the fine print after the fact that
same as cash is not the same as cash
because the interest will be triggered
and it's going to be retroactive to the
beginning
so have you done the calculation on that
I I have not no I actually tried to call
them and wasn't able to get through
that's convenient they'll happily give
you the money instantly but to get in
touch with them it's a nightmare so my
guess is this is a very very high
interest even higher than your normal
credit card probably in the high 20s
maybe even 30s
that will be triggered retroactively so
I would do everything in my power to
clean up this debt uh what's your other
debts that you have
um
well that goes into my next question we
have
um quite a bit of Home things that we
had to do
um student loans and
um two cars
um and my other question was about the
Cars one of the cars we are upside down
on and
um I've been listening for about a month
now to you guys so I didn't know if we
should sell that but then I don't have
the 5000 to cover the difference yeah so
either you'd have to come up with a
difference and then sell it to cover the
loan or the other option is getting a a
small loan from a credit union to cover
the difference and then attacking that
smaller one I don't love the second
option but it's the only time I would
say it's okay to go into debt is to
clean up a mess like this when you're
underwater on the car are you underwater
on the other car
no okay what's that one worth
um I think it's where it's about
17 and we owe about 17 on it okay
I might consider selling that car today
and do private party and do your
research with uh carvana you can try car
wiser you can try vroom and see how much
money you can get for that car because
if you can get 18 for that car and you
owe 17 well now we can clean up this
emergency vet debt
okay and so I would do some drastic
things to get out of this mess What's
the total debt you're in
oh gosh
um it's over a hundred and eighty
thousand including my student loans and
that doesn't that doesn't touch a
mortgage
no oh man what's the biggest debt out of
the 180.
um the biggest get is
okay and then you said you did some
house stuff are you saying like you did
a HELOC what'd you do to finance the
repairs
um yes we had uh we moved into a house
um and it had water in the basement
which became a whole big issue
um and we did not know that it had that
issue in the basement so we had to get
the whole basement fixed was it not
disclosed
um it was
I guess it it was but I mean how did an
inspector not catch that
I don't I don't know because the
bathroom tiles actually caved in and we
thought it was just a little water in
the bathroom but we started pulling up
the floor
well Felicia what is your household
income I hope it's really high
it's it's not as high as I want to be um
my husband and I combined make about
114. great can you put every penny from
the next few paychecks towards baby step
one and two and clean up this same as
cash loan and start these baby steps
yes yeah I I want to jump in it has the
every dollar app we have I've done the
beta thing to tell me when to put money
where but I am up for any suggestions
all right so then I'm gonna jump in on
that one and make a couple suggestions
so earlier in the call George asked you
are you willing
to work extra hours take on a second job
you know whatever and you were like I
think so
good but your husband needs to get a
second job and then you need to sell
stuff you work overtime then he needs
still using stuff I think we need to do
all right my point is I want you to take
off the limitations and and stop
thinking well I'm doing this I'm doing
this and I want to go how much more can
I do it's for a short season I
understand what I'm suggesting is not in
any way fun but I would tell you that
what I'm suggesting is doable
and I'm telling you to put the fire out
we do everything possible when the house
is on fire we don't go well I'm already
30 minutes into my Netflix show no it's
like put the fire out you know it's like
let's go and I think that you need that
urgency I understand you're tired I
understand you guys are already doing a
lot but we got ourselves into this we
can get ourselves out but it is going to
take Extreme Measures okay we're talking
urgency and I don't sense that in you
and I'm not beating up on you I'm just
trying to challenge you to say you can
do more sell everything get a fourth job
for a season I don't care I mean let me
just just so people don't think I'm
doing rah-rah stuff okay
if I'm the husband and I'm going to
speak to a dude here if I'm your husband
I'm going all right
um
how many nights a week could I do an
overnight shift at Walmart making 22 an
hour
just for a short term or you know like
how many nights could I do that you
stack that up times 10 nights 15 nights
in a month are you going to be exhausted
yeah but you could get out of this
situation pretty quick am I right George
yeah are you guys doing any investing
right now
no we stopped investing good are you
eating out right now
no do you get tax refunds every year
uh we do okay I would look at changing
my tax withholdings and I would get in
touch with a tax Pro because that means
the government's hanging on to your
money and right now you need that money
and so I want you to have a zero dollar
tax bill and make sure that you're
maximizing every dollar you have coming
in beyond that keep doing that budget
when you see any Bank transaction comes
in that you go we don't need to be
paying for that let's cut that
subscription no that's too much let's
not do that find any way you can get
really creative work as hard as you can
you guys have the income to do this it's
just a decision of are we going to go
all in or not
yes and me and Ken are more fired up
than you are at this point I think I'm
ready to tackle some dead
my husband he's like oh
I'm actually more fired up than he is
well play this back to it got him on
board well you know what I just spoke to
him a few seconds ago rewind it for him
get on the YouTube and I'm speaking to
him right now come on dude man up right
I will and he watched FPU as well he
went through lessons one two and three
he did okay let's check make sure he has
a pulse on him because I'm worried about
this guy does he understand the the fire
that you guys are in right now the mess
that you're in the interest rates that
are about to kick in
honestly I want to say no I think I
understand it more because I do all the
budgeting I do oh my goodness no Felicia
you've watched FPU that's all of that
that's not how this works this is a team
effort he needs to have input he needs
to have buy-in you're not going to do
anything for him that's why he's so
comfortable because you're taking on the
stress and weight of all this he doesn't
even know how broke he is show him on
paper show him tell him I'm stressed we
are not okay I am angry I'm frustrated
I'm anxious I can't live like this
anymore I need you to care as much as I
do
oh man Ken I'm fired up we need more
more men to step up in this country and
be the husbands that uh that we need in
America today this is this is Bad News
Bears
yeah I agree this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
every time you hear someone do their
debt free scream on the show it's
because at some point they said I've had
it I'm not living like this anymore and
when you get mad like that and do what
they did your life will change too and
right now inflation and your stupid
credit cards are killing you you've been
led to believe that you are not in
control of your money
but that's wrong you have to decide
what you can control and that's you your
behavior your money you have the power
to change your future and Financial
Peace University will show you how
this is the course that will teach you
the proven step-by-step plan that's
helped nearly 10 million people beat
debt Master budgeting and build wealth
and you can do this guys stop letting
debt and money stress control your life
all you need to do is start with three
magic words I've had it and take back
your control you can start Financial
Peace University right now at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU open phones this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour Diane joins us up next
in Hartford Connecticut Diane welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi guys thanks for taking my call happy
to take it um so I'm in baby steps five
and six and
um I have a question regarding my
flexible spending account
um through work okay I have a fifteen
hundred dollar deductible which I have
used up for the year
um and I do have the 10 saved for the
rest of my bills for this year
um I'm wondering if I should still keep
contributing a little bit out of my
paycheck each week or if I have the 1500
in the lump sum which I'll have in a
week should I set that aside
and use that now is this you said a
flexible spending account are you saying
that versus an HSA are you sure it's an
FSA
it's it's an HFA okay okay they're
different so I want to make sure I get
my Dex remote your flexible spending
accounts that money would run out at the
end of the year whereas an HSA that
money would roll over year to year oh
yeah it'll roll so okay great just
wanted to make sure so right now you
have no money in there
I have like twenty dollars right now
okay and you're thinking hey I'm gonna
need this money and I want to throw this
1500 bucks into the HSA
correct and then stop taking out of my
paycheck each week oh okay so you're
just splitting the difference and say do
I do lump sum now or do I let it roll in
with each future paycheck I mean where
you're at and baby steps you know five
and six it's fine if you want to throw
that lump sum in there uh me and my wife
we get an employer match in rhsa and so
at the beginning of the year we just
throw a pile of money into there we get
the match and we go great that
kickstarted our year off and so I see
this as the same type of thing where
we're throwing that in to cover the
deductible which will protect you later
on if there is some kind of Health
Emergency or you have big bills you'll
be able to cover that okay
um and I have a follow-up question on um
step five so I need to save ten thousand
total for both of my girls to go to
college because I get a discount
um and I have three more years until
they'll use that money so I've been
aiming to save three thousand a year
which I have a little over two thousand
for 22. should I continue to
get that ten thousand saved
um and then throw it all at the house or
should I stick to the three thousand a
year and put my extra stuff towards the
house payment
so you're saying should I put all my
focus in five
currently I are you putting this in a
savings account where is this money
going
um it's going in a savings account
because
um talking to my Edward Jones advisor at
529 at this point she didn't think was
the best plan sure because the short
time Horizon they're gonna need this
money pretty fast yeah I would put it as
in a high yield savings account at least
uh probably not no I would move it to an
online high yield savings account
because right now the interest rates
keep bumping up and so you can get you
know two and a half percent in there
instead of about zero in a normal Bank
savings account so it'll help that money
grow at least over three years as you
continue to throw some in there but I
would continue if you've got kind of a
looking at it like a sinking fund and a
budget where you say are I'm putting
this much every month into the college
account it's not gonna I'm not gonna
lose money because it's going to
continue to grow safely in that savings
account and after three years I know I'm
gonna have ten thousand and are you sure
it's going to be ten thousand for
college three years from now
um at today's prices it will be ten
thousand it goes up about three percent
a year so I will adjust it according
each year okay and hopefully three years
from now you make more money you're in a
better place financially than even you
were today and you're able to cash flow
anything remaining
correct that's the goal so I would do
that I wouldn't Focus all your energy
into that 10K for college right now just
keep adding you've got this thing uh
down you've got the plan and I like it
you're doing great because you sure do
thank you very much I appreciate it way
to go imagine this is like 1950s pricing
Ken ten thousand dollars for college I
know there are a lot of people going uh
I'd like the name of that college please
well it sounds like she's you know they
have a discount yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's a great benefit by the way yeah
by the way that's all that that ought to
be what it costs
yes you want to be fired up and then we
don't have time for that in this segment
but man the skyrocketing cost of tuition
well it is there's a lady out in the
lobby that wants me to go after it she's
not maybe we'll work the rant in later
I'll talk to James it'll fire you up if
you look at the soaring cost of tuition
and what it is done uh to our students
and our parents and family it's it's an
absolute racket oh yeah well we just uh
it's a great segue can we just aired
borrowed future yeah on demand for free
on YouTube for the very first time and
so if you want to get riled up like Ken
is right now you can go check that out
it's a 90-minute documentary and uh it's
been available to rent uh on our website
money platforms but right now it's
totally free yeah for the future yeah so
go watch it with your kids this weekend
spark that conversation and they're all
going to go I don't want to go 200 Grand
into debt no thank you I gotta throw
this in here very quick uh for people
who haven't heard me say it before but
for you parents that are in this
situation
um kids going to be coming into that age
soon about college there's a two-part
question that you've got to employ
is a degree the only way
for your kid to do what they want to do
the second question is is the degree the
best way
if the answer is not yes to either one
of those things slow your role swallow
your pride get over the fact that maybe
your kid is going to go a different path
and and and and it's going to be okay
college degree has become so much about
status
and an extended summer camp and I'm
willing to say it it makes a lot of
people uncomfortable but I don't care
because it's the truth now if it's the
only way and if it's the best way and
we've got the resources here to help you
do it but boy oh boy I mean this is a
marketing message that has just sucked
it's just like the I was ranting about
this early about pharmaceuticals and
credit cards it's a marketing message
you know to where parents I mean we've
down we've looked down our nose at the
trades
in our society we we Elevate White
Collar work and we poo poo
Blue Collar work as if it's a less than
life and I know so many blue-collar men
and women that are wealthy and
multi-millionaires not only that they're
employing people creating jobs the
heartbeat of our economy and yet we've
accepted this me included now I've long
since spit it out of my mouth
but we we've allowed ourselves to walk
into this message that well
kid needs to go to college or else
they're going to be a loser
and you know how many losers
are rocking college campuses right now
well look at them they graduate the path
to losing they graduate with a degree
and then they can't get a job and
they're angry they call my show
they call my show at 38. well I fell
into it well how was college man it was
great man I partied my face off you know
why don't you just go to Europe at that
point for a year and have a great time
because that most parents there you go
they grow up there Canada social
experience that's a great point if the
parenting message is well I think it's a
time to come of age oh here's an idea
take a gap year that they got to pay for
themselves and let them go drink their
face off in Europe if that's what you're
all about parents go Eat Pray Love and
eat some linguine and uh Italy call it a
day it's way cheaper than college so
there you go yeah live in a hostel yeah
that's great golly but it's true I mean
a lot of these folks with degrees
they're going kind of making 15 an hour
how do I make more while the guy who
went to trade school who's a plumber an
electrician they're making 50 60 70 80
an hour yeah
with no no four-year degree so you tell
me who's winning
and guess who's more useful the plumber
and the electrician because I need those
guys to come because I don't not touch
anything I said it before I'll say it
again I live in Tennessee if my air
conditioning unit goes out in the middle
of July the dude that shows up at my
house is more important to my wife than
I'll ever be that's a hero right come on
that's a good word good hour Ken my
thanks to all the folks in the booth
Austin James Ben Andrew Zach you name it
and of course you America we appreciate
you listening in we'll be back real soon
with more of the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsey Show Channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm George Campbell
host of the fine print entree leadership
podcast and co-host of smart money happy
hour joined by Ken Coleman host of the
Ken Coleman show all of those shows I
mentioned as well as the Ramsey show you
can find on the Ramsey Network on the
Ramsay Network app and anywhere you
listen to podcasts open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your money and with my friend Ken here
we can dive into all of your work
related issues and Ken it's amazing if
you had a Venn diagram of money and work
there is so much overlap there a lot of
tensions a lot of Crossroads people are
right going should I switch jobs should
I how do I increase my income I've got a
toxic situation how do I deal with this
so that I can get control of my greatest
wealth building tool my income that's
right and the reality is is that I think
there's a lot of people who are long
time listeners viewers new listeners and
viewers who think that you can't change
jobs you can't get a promotion while in
the baby steps
and it's just not true and so we you
know I I just want our listeners today
to realize you've got anything that's
work related that's really you're really
struggling with we'll change your name
location will be sensitive to that if
it's a sticky situation I'm here I know
there are issues out there and and I
love to help people with Clarity whether
it be I have no idea what I want to do
with my life help me figure it out I
know what I want to do but I don't know
how to get there or I I know what I want
to do I know how to get there but I feel
like I can't do it because I'm in debt
and I want to take those myths or take
those challenges and help you today so
let's go let's do this triple eight
eight two five five two two five be
brave give us a call and you can join
the conversation Jonathan kicks us off
in Seattle Washington Jonathan welcome
to the show
hey thanks for taking my call guys sure
what's happening
so his situation I'm 28 years old
um I have a car note that I have 22k
left on
um I do have thirty thousand dollars in
savings to pay it off
um right now
um but the thing is I'm also in graduate
school
um which is going to cost me exactly
what the amount that I have in savings
which is going to be 30k
um so my question here is I'm I've been
contemplating going ahead and going
ahead and paying off my car
um but that will leave me with just 8K
um you know I would have the cash flow
of school for that so my question is
should I pay off the car
um which I owe 22 on and be left with 8K
and cash flow the rest for college or
should I go ahead and keep making that
minimum payment on the car and keep the
30k as a cushion to get me to the school
um
um and just just just as I know I
actually use the car uh to drive through
Uber which brings me around 36 to 40 a
year so there's that so being in a
situation I'm just in a little bit of a
dilemma what I should be doing with the
savings that I have well the car is not
the the magic secret sauce to making
money with Uber it's you right it's you
getting out there turning the app on and
driving people around
yeah so I actually don't drive people I
just drive I just drop their food off oh
you're doing ubereats
yes okay sweet and you're making 36 to
40 000 a year
yep wow that's I I do like seven six
seven days a week without a day off
sometimes sometimes I do four days a
week while you're asking around
uh-huh wow how much do you have how much
is the grad school what what do you have
left on that bill
so uh I just started it's an online
program okay
um and it's it the total was like 35 of
all I've already made the the first 5
000 payment so now the rest of the bill
is going to be 30k around for the
completion of the program how long how
long is this going to take
uh it's going to be for the next two
years okay
yeah I think partially you can you can
cash flow a lot of this grad school I
love that you already have it in savings
but you also have this car debt hanging
around your neck here what is the car
worth
uh the cards actually work like 33 I
believe last time I checked but now it
could probably be like down to like 30.
what's your income but
for the year is it just two breeds
yeah that's that's the only thing I'm
doing right now I'm actually also
looking for a side job you know relating
to my degree okay uh but until I find
that job this is what I'm just doing too
I've got a question on the degree
because it plays into where George is
taking you on how we get out of this
what is the degree but what is the
graduate program in and and can you
pause it because it's still going to be
there presumably
um well the program is this is a cyber
security Masters program
um um I can most certainly pause it but
I'm just going to have to reapply it
whenever I'm ready a few years down the
line whenever that is
um I just started this program
um because I wanted to get my foot in
the I.T industry as fast as possible
um
because I have an international
political study undergrad which is not
related to I.T and um well you want to
do cyber security
correct yes I also have a few years of
I.T experience Pro you know aside from
colleagues when I was in undergrad I
used to sell computers and whatnot so
that's what kind of got me interested in
this program
okay Georgia you think it's a two-year
play to get where he needs to get to
where he can jump back in and cash flow
I don't think it's that alone I've got a
great life hack for you I'm selling this
car because number one you've got a car
that's worth 33 000 and you make 36.
that's a lot of your life tied up in a
car yeah and so you sell that car for 33
you owe 22. well guess what that puts
you at 11 000 in cash in the bank
without touching your 30. yeah so now
let's go buy an 11 000 car we have the
money set aside for the grad program
bada bing bada boom there he is Jersey
George right there he's back he comes
his that character just emerges when he
lays out great advice what do you think
Jonathan would you be willing to sell
this car
while the Market's still hot survey says
um
that's a hard pass that was a bad radio
pause is a pass Jonathan uh where are
you willing to do what George just
proposed
yeah for sure but um but this is also my
daily Drive other other than just
ubereats this is what I do but yeah I
see what you guys are saying can an 11
000 car not be a daily driver that does
Uber uh it it it can be I'm I I see what
you guys are saying yeah I don't see a
reason to justify the thirty thousand I
got another option I got another option
because Jonathan's struggling on this
okay Jonathan I got another angle
um I want you to contact Bethel Tech the
website is betheltech.net I endorse them
um Ramsey solutions they are one of our
partners they have a training program an
online training program that will get
you into cyber security for fifteen
thousand dollars that's quite the
discount there's a big difference I'd
talk to them that's what I would I like
that plan and on top of that I'm still
selling the car I'm still selling the
car and uh be glad Dave's not here
because he'd just be like sell the
freaking car Jonathan you're broke yeah
we just we just got you out of all this
we're gonna get you out of the car debt
and we're gonna get you into cyber
security way faster talk to Bethel Tech
guess what the people getting the food
from ubereats they don't care if you
drive a 33 000 car or a ten thousand
dollar car they just want I just want my
pasta man they're what I don't know what
accent was that but it was offensive
skin Jersey George this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey guys in case you missed it yesterday
we announced new spring live event dates
for our building Wells life I know I'm
sure it's sold out it was so popular
this fall that we're going to take it to
some new cities in 2023. where are we
going George we are going to
Indianapolis oh February 16th we're
going Colts Austin Texas oh February
21st all right and then Anaheim May 2nd
oh Anaheim so we've got a little bit of
everything fun to get out to Southern
California yeah Indy Austin Anaheim so
February 16th February 23rd May 2nd
people all across the country they're
wanting to know Ken is it still possible
to build wealth in this inflationary
times in this economy it is you can do
it we're going to show you how Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman and myself we're going to walk
you through a simple but proven plan to
build wealth invest make smart decisions
no matter what's going on with the
economy and here's the best part tickets
are just 39 bucks and they sell out fast
because of that and I want to mention we
have a little uh pre-show option which
is a robust q a with me and Dr John
deloney we talk about powerful moments
we talk about the tension between our
work life and our relationship life and
it always turns out to be really great
so that's a that's an additional
offering but we do do that before the uh
and it's the main event if you get
tickets to show up early and you can
enjoy that and we do have VIP tickets
but we only have 200 of those and they
always sell out quick and that includes
a meet and greet with Dave and so don't
wait go get your seats for these events
ramseysolutions.com events is the place
to go hope to see you all across the
country uh in 2023 it's gonna be a good
time yeah it's always fun to get out
there can't wait to be in Dallas this
weekend that's right just a few days
away
Saturday Dallas Texas going to be a
unbelievable I believe it's Frisco is
that where the venue is I believe it is
I don't know it's the Curtis Caldwell
Center yeah I think I don't know
anything about cities can I just go
where they tell me it's going to be fun
well not too late to join us for that
either and all day Saturday event coming
up alright open phones this hour at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
work life your financial life your whole
life
Rick joins us up next in Ann Arbor
Michigan Rick welcome to the show
oh thank you so much for having me on uh
that listen to your show all the time
and I also looked at his daughter's uh
YouTube uh oh yeah Rachel Cruz show
well thank you so much Rick how can we
help today
uh been a fan for many years my daughter
recommended you a number of years ago so
you helped her too anyways uh I'm 76
years old and I'm 97 000 in debt
my income is four thousand dollars
okay where's the income come from
uh two from mine and my wife's Social
Security
and her uh a retirement pension okay and
that adds up to four thousand dollars a
month
yeah and she's been working part-time
and I've been trying to work part-time
so her total expenses are a little over
ten thousand a month
total expenses what is that coming from
the debt the debt interest
credit card yes so is the 97 000 all
credit card debt
uh
97 000
is uh debt
and I just had it down either my battery
ran off oh there's about a little under
50 000. of credit card debt what's the
other types of debt
uh let's see I got it
my truck is 6.75.
uh What's the total alone on the truck
uh 18 933 okay do you know what it's
worth by chance
uh well with the mileage on it it's
probably worth about that okay I've got
almost 300 000 miles on it all right
that that still leaves us another what
twenty nine thousands or so in debt
what's the other debt you got the truck
the credit cards what else
uh I got my wife's car
okay what's left on that loan
you take him
is it more than the truck three yeah
three no three thousand ninety two
dollars oh okay
and there's still a whole bunch left
there on top of that so if you gotta
walking through the dead snowball we got
to figure out these cars as well yeah
Rick number one I it's not going to be
fun or easy but these cars need to go
it's one of the only kind of reversible
debts you have on this list because we
can't sell the credit card debt back to
the company but we can sell these cars
and potentially get out of a chunk of
this
my truck I use for work you got the
truck on what are you doing for work I
don't know what's your income I haul uh
recreational vehicles
I drive to Indiana pick up an RV from
the manufacturer and take it to dealers
all over the country but that any truck
can do that it doesn't need to be a
twenty thousand dollar truck right
well it has to be a big truck I've got a
Ford F-350 and Diesel that's I do
understand that I think the bigger issue
is what's a better line of work for you
uh where where we're not having very
difficult because I've got extreme
health problems I've had two different
cancers I've had the heart bypass I've
had carotid bypass but calling all this
equipment across state lines that feels
like a heck of a lot of work for a guy
in your shape then
well no I'm just driving I can do that
all right well and then my wife she
needs hers to work
well I still think we need to sell these
cars and get cheaper versions that we
can pay cash for that's the bottom line
because there's not a lot of wiggle room
here we're not going to make you know
triple the income
and let me let me ask a follow-up here
is that Rick is the 4 000 a month income
that includes the Social Security Plus
you and your wife working part-time jobs
no okay so it's more than four thousand
yeah we've been we've been we've been
scraping up to ten thousand
uh okay so you're saying you have ten
thousand a month for the expenses you're
making up the gap of six thousand
dollars with your part-time work
together
yes okay all right that's a little bit
different actually actually I say it's
not you know mine is really not
part-time part-time yeah you know I go
all the time okay all right the picture
has changed for a couple weeks yes so
they're scraping 10 grand a month
together so now the question is how can
we get we've got to reduce expenses yeah
I mean I want you guys to be able to
retire Rick isn't that the goal
to not have to do this anymore
yes I'm going to be 77 in January and uh
just this past month my wife came up
with breast cancer
now she's out of work but to me that
that changes the whole picture Rick I go
what needs to be true for us to be able
to retire for us to take care of
ourselves and deal with these health
issues and that means I'm sacrificing by
getting rid of these cars that have debt
on them and if that means I get a real
old truck that still gets the job done
or even change my line of work I'm going
to be willing to do that because you're
gonna need to be home pretty soon to
help take care of your wife it's going
to be hard to be on the road all the
time
do you have anything Rick that you can
sell
do you have other assets that you can
sell that we would have to change your
life in retirement accounts savings
accounts
no no actually we're worse than broke
our bank account is 980 in the hole oh
my God and the bank's been working with
me they're not charging me to you know
nsfd so I do have a boat
but I've been trying to sell it and
what's it worth
uh probably about ten thousand Lio three
on it I would definitely sell the boat
make it more attractive you know drop
the price a little bit to get rid of
that debt plus come up with a little
extra cash I would hope to sell the boat
right now and pay off the boat and then
pay off your wife's car
all right that's that's a start now we
got some momentum how would that feel I
want you to just take yourself there how
would that feel if you did that with one
with one sale
I'd feel pretty good well that's a start
and as you keep doing that you're going
to free up more and more of these
payments which means that 10K can go a
lot further and help you knock out other
debts but Rick this is an emergency
situation we've got to just sell
anything that's not tied down to as much
work as we can under 76 I mean now is
the time to start the best time to plant
the tree was 10 years ago the next best
time is today and so let's get about the
business of cleaning this mess up
because for 76 years we've been having a
good time buying boats but now it's time
to go we want to retire we got to take
care of our health and we can't live
like this anymore so we're wishing you
the best cleaning up this mess get the
help from the kids that you need as
since they're fans as well appreciate
the call man this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more more
bursts
[Music]
I'm George Campbell he's Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsay show give us a call
at
888-825-5225 I can jump in and help with
those money questions Ken is an expert
at helping you with your work problems
whether it's switching jobs a toxic boss
moving States you're trying to upgrade
the income to you know hit some money
goals Ken can help in that area for sure
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jackie is up in New York City
Jackie welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you doing great how are you
what's going on
oh we have gotten it for around 270
um thousand and it basically worked
double right now
so we are kind of like should we sell
the house pay off the debt and then
we'll be able to still buy another house
because we'll still be up with what we
make on it
um so that's kind of like where we're at
I don't know run run the numbers for us
how much debt do you have
so
9 000 instead okay
um the house that we bought we got it
for 270 and it's worth about like 470
now
um
and that's really the numbers so keep
playing it out so you sell it for 470
you pay the house off well what do you
owe on it
um so yeah so we owe Pro um actually I
have my mortgage thing right here
um
the total oh I don't know oh we owe 262.
okay all right so you don't you don't
have much in this house when you bought
it and so you're gonna get out of this
thing probably 175 after fees
Yeah
Yeah so basically um when I worked on
the numbers just before we would we'd
get around like 140 000 after like
paying off that paying off our debt
paying off all of that all together
including the car the 39. yeah well that
you'd be at 140 and you were saying you
felt like you could get into another
house with that is that right
yeah like we figured either uh you know
we could put another deposit like on
another house because even if we're up
even to say even a hundred thousand
after paying off that you know the works
you could still take a you know we could
still put 50 000 to a new house and then
we would be debt free with just a new
mortgage My worry is that mortgage is
going to be huge what's your income
um so my um husband is an electrician so
he makes about 55 000 a year
um and I'm like a seasonal restaurant
worker so I'm like around like 35. so
what would the cost of the new house be
um I mean I think we would probably
stay around 300 000 just like how we
once were like we didn't really you know
but again the market is up so happens do
you think you're gonna find a house for
300 000 in your area
um that's as good as the one you have
I'm like
not as good but it would definitely have
to be something that's like lower like
you know and you have to fix it up like
the area that we in like where we live
in like it has a lot of fixer-uppers
I just think we're doing a lot of work
here when you guys could pay off 39 000
making 90.
why not just attack the debt instead of
do this like shortcut and uproot your
life and go to a worse house with lower
quality of living yeah all to pay off
the debt I'd rather you sell the car
before you sell the house right and it's
all car debt isn't it
um well it's 15 000 in credit cards and
then 25 000 in the car loan okay well
how much is the car worth
right now I'm sure we got to find that
out
how much money do you have in the bank
um between savings checking
um I believe we're probably about like
40 000 in the bank what are we doing
here Jack all right hold on hold on hold
on
yeah
you feel a position right now we also
want to try to open up a business or
something with even the equity on the
house slow your roll Jackie let's slow
down here here's what we're gonna do you
have 40 000 in the bank you owe 39 you
pay it off completely today that leaves
you with a thousand dollars scary right
yeah but guess what you now don't have
any payments so that Nets that next
paycheck and the next one stays with you
now we build a fully funded emergency
fund while we don't owe anyone anything
and that's what we call baby step three
that's the emergency fund baby step two
and the Ramsay plan is paying off all
Consumer Debt using the debt snowball so
you can fast forward through baby steps
one and two uh and start working on
three today
um but part of the reason you're here
going I don't know why we're not feeling
the progress should we sell our house
when we're in this mess we just need to
do one thing at a time with focused
intensity and right now let's clean up
the debt
with the money we have in the bank let's
get an emergency fund and let's reassess
if you want to move for another reason
that's fine but do not move to pay off
this debt and I want to I want to jump
in George's George's advice is spot on
but I just want to drive drive in on an
emotional Point here well do you know
what your car payment is every month
roughly
60 a month okay I want you to just
process instead of the fear of going
from 40 000 in your savings account to
one thousand I want you to process that
400 plus dollar a month payment going
away and your credit card bill and the
credit card what are you paying on your
credit card
well it's like multiple credit cards but
total total
the total is fifteen thousand in credits
no no no no no your monthly payments to
the credit card company is what
a few hundred bucks okay probably about
like 700 bucks all right now watch watch
it watch what just happened
in one Fell Swoop you no longer have
eleven hundred dollars a month due how
does that feel I want you to chew on
that one for a second how does that feel
you know that those seem a little bit
nicer there we go so we got a narrative
issue going on here it's not George I'm
going to deplete my savings you'll feel
safe you're not you're actually going to
free up Eleven Hundred plus dollars a
month
and have no debt and don't have to move
in here you have to move you have your
house you have your mortgage but the
point is is like you're free of Consumer
Debt and you don't have to move
what I know you're gonna probably be
like no equity line of credit but like
as far as trying to keep some type of
value out of the house you don't think
we should do that not in a thousand
years I wouldn't wish it upon my worst
enemy no because you're in great shape
with that house Jackie you guys can then
begin to pay off that house you know
it's going backwards
okay that's what it's doing I want you
guys to be debt free not in more debt
and keep pulling Equity out of the house
because you know what happens then
you're calling me at 65 years old going
hey we have a mortgage and we got credit
cards and we don't know how we got here
but we want to retire we're sick of
working but we can't instead I want you
to call us and say we are net worth
millionaires we have a paid for house
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars we don't owe anyone anything we
have a million dollars in our retirement
because we had the margin to fund it
with that extra eleven hundred dollars
and now we're in a different place
financially we sleep better we can move
where we want to move you see what that
does to your life yeah yeah and so part
of it is we got to stop justifying all
the numbers in our head and what could
be and what could happen instead go what
is our reality today how do we make
today better and part of that is we
don't need to live with payments anymore
and by the way when you pay off these
credit cards would you cut them up would
you be willing to do that for just a
month cut them up close the accounts and
see if you can survive a month using a
debit card
um yeah I mean we could probably do that
you know we do like the you know Home
Depot and those cards you know like what
does it do for you
I love can I tell you how much I love
home improvement stores they make me
happy but I don't have a card with them
I just use my debit card but Ken you can
save 10 on that buzz saw that you need
for that one project today let me tell
you something I didn't say I like to use
I don't even know how to use everything
on those aisles I just like being in
there it makes me very happy you know
it's kind of a man thing but hey I'm
going to challenge you on something I'm
gonna throw something in here George
because Jackie I think I'm trying to
save you a little bit more money George
tell me if I'm wrong let's say her car
let's say she's got five or ten Grand of
equity in that car and you sell the car
and you downgrade in car for a little
bit and that allows you to save more of
that 40 000 right because we removed the
debt on the car and I keep and I got a
big head start on my emergency fund
that's true I was driving a nuts not as
nice car but who gives a crap park
around the corner no one needs to see it
so Jackie you have a lot of options but
the one option I'm not going to say is
okay is the house is to just sell the
house to clear the debt it's a bad
shortcut and I only recommend it if
you're in a real real terrible situation
you guys make good money it's just time
to put it to use and stop playing games
with Home Depot and messing around with
these credit card companies and it's
what got you into this into this mess
and uh I want you to have freedom and
part of that means we're saying no to
the store credit card here just say this
next time no thank you have a nice day
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Ken Coleman this hour
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five art joins us up
next in Denver Colorado art welcome to
the show
hey thanks for taking my call guys sure
how you doing
I'm doing well so
after doing your baby steps I'm on step
four
invest 15 and I've been there for a few
months I don't plan on having children
and I don't have a calm I was curious
what your thoughts are about living a
digital Nomad lifestyle I live I work a
remote job
and uh do pretty well for myself I have
no debt and I don't really know where to
go from here I want to
become more mobile
I currently live in a on my uncle's
property with a very cheap rent and
could easily pay this and just leave my
stuff here instead of have to get rid of
everything
so what are the downsides of not buying
real estate in the market right now and
kind of living my childhood dream and
waiting
uh I don't I don't hear any downsides
you know because yeah but that sounds
too good to be true what's too good
about it to be true
lots of people do it
yes I know is your plan now you gotta
have a plan are you gonna live in an RV
a camper how are you going to travel I
have a
like I said I have no debt I've got
about 12 Grand to throw at
go into to do the camper thing without
touching my emergency funds okay
and
I don't know I'm kind of hesitant to
pull the trigger because I've been
trying to live frugally these past few
years and get out of the hole that I did
that I dug in my 20s right but are you
saying 12 Grand is going to pay cash for
something or is that
ideally or I have access to personal
interest-free loans from uh we're not
doing that no no no no no no no no no
we're not going to recommend it why'd
you get out of debt in the first place
if you're going to get back into it
yeah see that's kind of what I'm
thinking okay
really wants to go for it all right
we're on the same page now so how much
do you make doing this remote I make
about 85 000 a year so how long would it
take for you to save up the actual full
cost of 40 grand for a good camper
yeah I would say I could do it by late
next year well there you go if I
buttoned up and and really I think you
can get better than that you said you
have almost no expenses
correct so how long would it take to
save up 30 make an 85 with very little
expenses
um
not that long but I'm I'm
scared of debt now that I've gotten out
of it and so we're not I just want to
take it slow okay but again we're not
encouraging we're not encouraging debt
George is just saying how much quicker
could you make the thirty thousand maybe
what I'm saying is how you know out of
your paychecks could you take two or
three grand and put it in a high yield
savings account every single month
yes that puts you at another 30 grand
add it to the 12. and and that gives you
a 42 000 RV camper
and now
we just travel and you live that dream
and you continue to do it debt free you
have a paycheck coming in from the
remote job you need to make sure you
have internet access and uh some people
are doing you know they have internet
access from the camper at all times you
can look into those options as well
so what's the I think the the truth is
it sounds like there's some fear around
jumping into this digital Nomad
lifestyle have you talked to someone
who's done it
uh no I haven't I've been taking Dave's
advice and talking to the old rich
people that I know because that's who I
want to be we'll also jump into the
those communities online and go hey I'm
new to this what are some things I need
to look out for go jump onto some
Facebook groups some Reddit threads and
see what people are saying about this
lifestyle the UPS the Downs The Good the
Bad and uh and then you can jump in
knowing exactly what to expect
okay and guess what happens three years
from now if you hate this and you go you
know what I want to settle down I want
to sleep in the same bed every day you
can just stop and decide to do something
different
it's not the rest of your life don't
don't take on more debt even if it's
interest-free just be patient is let me
ask you a question is the dream does the
dream include you driving the camper or
dragging it behind you or is the dream I
want to go here for three days and then
if I feel like going somewhere else for
four days is it a combo or is the camper
in the RV thing a big part of the Stream
it's really just going I just don't like
looking out the window and seeing the
same thing every day okay I had a hunch
that that was the case and so uh now
that I know that I wouldn't touch the
camper with a 10-foot pole unless you
were into that kind of thing because
that's a asset that is going to go down
it's going to depreciate very very
quickly into George's point if you get
out on this digital Nomad thing and I
just want to go and then I've bought
this thing that's that's depreciating
then that's a pain in the neck down the
road if I change my mind versus you're
debt free you got a good amount of cash
saved up you can save up even more and
if and if you just decide I'm gonna
drive
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna buy a real
gas Friendly Car uh or if you've already
got one a very dependable car I'm gonna
drive here and then I'm gonna drive
there or if you can afford to I'm Gonna
Fly here and then I'll fly there if it's
about moving around
and and you can do your work from
anywhere then this is you coming up with
a budget and a plan to go all right
since I don't have rent anymore and I
know what my income is and if I look at
okay and George you're the king of this
so like budget friendly hotels so if I
find a chain and I become a frequent
rewards person and I'm paying cash for
the hotel rooms and I'm going right I
can pay this and so I've got a budget of
and so I know what my hotel and my food
cost and and if I'm flying versus
driving this is just putting all that
together and going okay this is what it
looks like and if I can only do it 20
days a month based on those financial
realities I know I'm living with my
uncle the other 10 days
but I would stay away from the camper in
the RV knowing what I know now
what do you think art
okay I think that's more reasonable I
guess I'm really more afraid of not
having all my stuff that I've always had
what's done
well I mean I've never not stayed in a
house for more than like 10 12 days at a
time then here's the idea first of all
you already said you could store your
stuff with Uncle all right that's one
option but the other option is before we
commit to this full time why don't we
just try this a week at a time for the
next three months what if we take the
next three months and for one week we
try this new lifestyle
and we just sit back and go huh
I always wondered what it was like now
I'm going to test it without committing
full-time yeah how old are you are okay
I'm 31. okay yeah I like testing this
I just think you need to take the
pressure off of yourself as if you step
into this and this has to be your life
for the next 40 years regardless of what
happens
okay I think that's where my stress is
coming from like what if I don't like it
once I get out there so here's a great
news up in the car first yeah and then
that's ensure that that works yeah try
that whole hotel thing yeah especially
responsibly that's it try it on a mini
level right we're gonna mini commit to
this thing we're going to test it and
then the testing is going to clarify all
of this for you and you're gonna go ding
ding ding or and you might realize you
know what this ain't for me that's right
and that's okay you might just go I need
to travel at least once a month and have
a trip to look forward to and that's
good enough for me yeah but as long as
you do it debt free there's no there's
no need to stress about the stability of
going into debt if you just say I'm just
a guy who doesn't go into debt I'm not
going to do interest-free loans I'm not
going to owe anyone anything I'm going
to use my debit card I'm going to pay
cash for the RV I'm going to have an
emergency fund for all the expenses
involved with this and I know what to
expect so jump into those communities
ask those types of questions they're
always happy to talk about it and share
their experiences even share their
numbers of here's what the actual cost
is I thought it was going to be
basically living for free turns out it's
seven thousand dollars a month if you
want to do it big and so get do your
homework do the research
um but I don't see any issue with you
jumping into this
it's that simple good stuff there that
was fun yeah it's a new you know I've
got a musician Buddy who lives out of
his van and he really enjoys it I've got
another friend out in California who
runs a digital agency out of a converted
Airstream yeah and he loves it he's on
the he opens the door he's on the sand
on the beach he's got internet wherever
he goes I love that so it can be a great
lifestyle for a lot of people it is I do
have a question uh for your friend who's
a musician who lives in a van is it Down
by the River I don't think it's down by
the river but he is in uh here in
Nashville so he could be by the uh the
Old River downtown yeah what river is
that I don't know someone knows it's not
the tennis the Cumberland guy the
Cumberland all right thanks James always
coming in the clutch that puts this hour
of the Ramsay show in the books
appreciate all of you listening my
thanks to Ken Coleman all the guys in
the booth we'll be back with you before
you know it
foreign
[Music]
folks Ken Coleman here did you know the
Ramsay show is one of the most popular
podcasts in the world to get your daily
dose of advice on life and money check
out all of our shows from the Ramsay
Network wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell joined by
Ken Coleman this hour open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your work life your financial life
and your whole life and by the way if
you like this show which I assume you do
because you're still listening please
consider subscribing giving us a follow
where you're listening leaving a review
and sharing it with a friend we want to
impact as many people as possible with
this show and all of that helps us
accomplish that uh George you know I
have the utmost respect for you your
friend and and companion sitting next to
me here in the office but you just a
weird disclaimer the way you opened up
the show there that you kind of said and
we'll talk about your whole life now we
will talk about how bad whole life
insurance policy that is true but that
is not what you were emphasizing no I
meant your your whole uh entire life
person yeah see but we will we'll tell
you if you've got a whole life policy
we'll destroy that there's uh we'll
destroys my gears like those whole life
salesmen can I'll tell you grinds your
gear it's a real gear grinder well good
good for you I've got some WD-40 over
here under thank you for that if things
get too too grindy it wouldn't shock me
can he runs on Tums and WD-40 that's all
you need that's right two of my
unofficial sponsors
laughs oh I love it all right let's get
to some calls before they take us off
the air Paul joins us up in Oklahoma
City Paul welcome to the Ramsay show
hey thanks good afternoon my son is
getting married in about a year and a
half my wife initially thought we'd uh
pay for their honeymoon and stuff like
that but then some other folks suggested
we do a an investment uh for them so
with that said the investment any ideas
what might work for a newlywed couple
that they can you know get later in life
okay so you want to give them some sort
of
yeah probably about two or three yeah
probably two or three thousand dollars
okay and why an investment for the
retirement versus something that
kick-starts their marriage today
um good question no answer it's just all
right yeah well he's thinking he's
looking he's looking he's not going to
get a newlywed couple it's like what I
need is money today not 30 years from
now so I think it's a lovely idea and
you can encourage them to use that money
to you know put it in a Roth IRA
yeah they're both working in a small
Tennessee Town making about sixty
thousand dollars so they're they're a
decent shape are they do they will they
have any debt
uh my son bought a car and uh that's
about it okay so who's paying for the
actual wedding
uh her mom and dad completely they're
covering it yes yes sir okay and you
want to cover the honeymoon
but now you're not so sure we thought
about covering a honeymoon but we
thought about giving them a long-term
investment that maybe you know when they
get 40 50 they can have a little Nest
Egg of some sort
yeah I mean they can say for their own
retirement if they're young right how
old are they
uh 25 and 23. okay
so they're they're plenty young are they
aware of our the Ramsey principles and
the power of getting started early with
investing in compound interest uh uh no
uh he knows that I went through
Financial Peace University about seven
or eight years ago
how much does he owe on his car
uh 376 dollars a month but What's the
total loan
uh seventeen thousand dollars okay
and what's his income you said there's
60 combined yeah he's making about 32.
yeah that's a lot of car to be making I
would encourage him to rethink the car
but I think George correct me if I'm
wrong your hesitation on putting two or
three grand in a you know a mutual fund
sure they're gonna have to keep
contributing to that I mean you can just
let it sit for 30 years but I'm like the
kids got dead on his car Let's help him
today that's where I'm at or you know
and money that they don't have to spend
on their honeymoon is a very nice
gesture so that they can you know and
I'd really encourage your son to pay the
car off quickly start paying it off now
as a matter of fact I thought you said
the wedding is a year or a year and a
half from now is that right right right
five five four twenty four I would have
I would really encourage him to pay that
car off and go into marriage debt free
great because I'm paying 100 towards the
principal maybe I'll just add it up a
little bit more and help them out
um so the principal of his car no no you
need to tell him to put his big boy
pants on
you don't you shouldn't be paying his
car payment he's agree he's a grown he's
a grown man
yeah he is does he want to pay this
thing off real good money My worry is
he's just comfortable because Dad's
helping him pay the car payment and he
feels like life is pretty good
I want I want them to have a little fire
under his butt to go I want you to have
this car paid off by the time yeah
you're married
I got great news I'm gonna pay for your
honeymoon but I'm not paying for your
car anymore you know I like that I like
that leverage because guess what happens
when he gets married with 17 000 in car
loan debt it becomes her debt too and
what does that do to their marriage when
they say I do oh by the way we now owe
this debt that you didn't sign up for
and so I think getting started on on the
right foot with marriage is great and
one of the best ways to do that is for
them to go through Financial Peace
University yeah could you gift that to
them with a thousand dollar check
and say hey absolutely let's do this
thing I just got you guys started oh I
like that church we got all kinds of
ideas Paul but uh I think today is the
phone call and we cut the umbilical cord
uh you shouldn't pay another nickel
towards his car I think I'm old school
but I'm more of a teacher man a fish
kind of guy and so if you teach him how
to invest well he's got another 35 40
years to do that to become a millionaire
what do you know about fishing well it's
a it's a metaphor Ken yeah Paul he
doesn't know anything about fishing but
you get the you know Ken's always out
there with the He's Got The Reeling Rod
I don't know anything about fishing
either for the record but Paul I think
we got some good ideas here you feel
good
yeah bless you gentlemen thank you very
much happy to help okay bye now good
stuff have a good one man that's
interesting Ken that's a it's an
interesting conversation because a lot
of parents do want to like that guy yeah
uh that's a nice gesture you know and uh
but boy you shouldn't be paying your
your adult kids car payments folks
that's a dangerous move
one that sets a precedent that this
isn't really on me if if this doesn't
work out dad can cover it it's not the
kid's fault I mean what kid's gonna say
no dad I mean you know a few High
character people would but it's like you
got to be kidding me yeah you know
um but part of it is showing them hey
you know what if you saved you know 300
bucks a month that that's 3 600 bucks a
year and two years from now you could
afford a 7 200 car and when you work and
save up that kind of money Ken you make
your car purchase a whole lot
differently I like that I like how you
got him started with the emergency fund
I thought that was a nice I thought that
was a really good idea it's a fun thing
to do and I always like including it
with you know if you don't just gift
Total Money Makeover Financial Peace
University right you know sneak the 100
bill in The Total Money Makeover so hey
if you go through Financial Peace
University I'm gonna give you a thousand
bucks when you guys finish it so you put
it or somewhere middle chapter three
just to see I like the problem is I
please do not send that book to Goodwill
with 100 bucks in it yeah oh as you like
to say George teach a man to fish there
we go I love saying it I love to fish
take me fishing deloney will take us Dr
John he's a big fisherman yeah I gotta
catch it quickly or I'm out I have I
have ADHD I need to catch the fish right
away it's a young man's game yeah hey
more your calls coming up triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour this is the Ramsey
Show well folks you've heard the news we
are in a recession the stock market is
falling inflation's out of control all
right calm down for a second
if you're investing this is no time to
panic you've got to stay level-headed do
not jump off the investing roller
coaster because all of the gloom and
doom you're hearing a lot of people are
messaging me saying hey I need to pull
out of the stock market pull out of my
401k it's too scary I keep seeing it go
down this is not the time to jump
history shows us that the economy
recovers time and time again it happened
after the Great Depression 911 and the
Great Recession of 08. so here's the
crazy news this is actually a great time
to invest because when the Market's down
it's on sale and who doesn't love a good
deal but you've got to be smart about
this and have someone who can guide you
through it so if you need help finding
an investing Pro check out our
smartvestor program it's an easy way to
find Pros who truly serve with
Excellence they'll be there to help you
figure out what's best for you and keep
you focused on your long-term goals and
talk you off a ledge when you're
thinking about pulling all the money out
of your 401k
so if you want to get connected with up
to five smartvestor Pros in your area go
to ramseysolutions.com
smartvester you can talk with those Pros
pick the one you want to work with and
then make an investing plan you feel
confident about again that's
ramsaysolutions.com smartvester
open phones this hour at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Amber
joins us up next in Springfield Missouri
Amber welcome to the show
oh thank you for having me yeah how are
you doing what's going on yeah oh well
um my husband and I sold out of our old
business and we're getting ready to
start a new business our building is
pretty much up and ready to go except
for electrical and stuff but we're
hoping to be open in November sometime
well my main question is uh it's just
going to be me and my husband working
and it's an automotive repair shop and
we are going to be paying ourselves a
weekly paycheck
um just because that's going to be our
only source of income and then whatever
we have for the business like we'll pay
tithes out of our weekly income that we
have but my main question is will the
business need to pay tithes as well
no you would just do that off of what
you take home
just what I take home okay yes so if
you're if you're doing that you are in
good shape uh I have not found anything
to back up a business tithing from the
business and so it would all come from
the net profit that you take home into
your home what you file your tax return
on that is your income and so that's
what I would be timing on
okay
great yeah well that was an easy answer
um I'm so glad we needed an easy win
today Ken didn't yeah anytime we can get
an easy one it's good yeah congrats good
luck with the new auto repair shop we
need some good hearted people out there
in Auto Repair who are honest mechanics
Can it can be scary it's true no one
wants to get ripped up true except for
in Springfield go check out Amazon shop
in November there you go there we go
Greg is up next in Cincinnati Greg
welcome to the show
[Music]
Greg Greg are you with us buddy
yes okay how's it going
I'm great how are you guys appreciate
your show sure thank you so
um we are
um in our home for just over one year
and
um our septic system needs to be
replaced and so we're just kind of weigh
in different options in regards to which
financial route
um to go because the cost of septic we
do not have in the savings right now
okay
do you know how much it's going to cost
have you uh got some bids from different
folks
yes so we are um we've gotten four
different bids
um the one I think we're gonna go with
is thirty four thousand thirty four
hundred or thousand
thirty four thousand that feels
outrageous
uh it's a large septic system on on a
farm property okay wow did you know that
the septic system was on its last leg
when you moved in
um so we bought the property
um as is because of the potential that's
in it
um and we knew that needed some
replacing
um but they thought they'd be able to
um
fix it in regards to replacing the whole
thing and then once they open it up um
it did need fully replaced
okay well what kind of financial shape
are you guys in
um so the only debt that we have
currently is our mortgage all cars are
paid off
um
and so our mortgage is currently 160.
um
okay
how much do you have in the bank
we currently have six thousand
all right and do you have anything you
can sell
um no we're kind of out of stand still
um we're a single income family I'm
almost teacher then my wife stays home
with our youngest
um and
like I said we're gonna understand so we
paid all cars and stuff off before we
moved and then
um we do have a slight extra income with
it being a Farm property we rent out
more stalls
um okay what's that bring in an extra
three 350 a month 350. and what's here
um yearly at 56 000. okay
so the question becomes how are we able
to cash flow this septic system correct
correct now how long would this process
take have you talked to the companies
and hey this says six month project is
it something they do in a day I have no
idea
um so it would take approximately two
weeks okay to complete and is the septic
system working now
it's working
um there's no like backup into the home
however
um with us having six people in the home
um it fills up quicker than it should
simply because of the leaks in it who
are the people
myself my wife and then four uh children
from ages nine to two okay
so it is it's a party and so what is the
septic system company that you're
looking to go with are they requiring to
deposit
um are they what how are you going to do
this before you called us I mean what
what are the options I'm assuming they
know that you don't have 35 000 or
whatever it's going to cost up front
correct and that's why I was calling
we've explored
um home equity loans and second
mortgages so that's why I was calling to
see what you guys kind of suggest as far
as moving forward we're very
um driven and regards to getting it paid
off
um like we were with our cars
um but are they asking for it all up
front or all upon completion I mean
what's the what are they offering
upon completion yes so paid in full
that's the deal
right which means if they started today
two weeks from now you owe thirty four
thousand dollars which you don't have
correct and we have talked to several
companies because of the weather here in
Ohio since it is still functioning there
um if it gets to be too late in November
then they would recommend waiting to the
spring
um so we've explored obviously building
up some extra savings wait until the
spring I mean how much of an emergency
situation is this is it going to cause
more damage
no um simply because nothing's backing
up into the home
um it won't cause more damage it's just
it's one of those things that has been
aged and
um needs to be replaced we can kick it
to the spring then I'm definitely doing
that it sound I thought it sounded like
this has to happen tomorrow
no um it's something that um as soon as
possible but it's not mandatory to be
done
um and you're and you're saying there's
no risk of this thing backing up into
the house and causing even more
financial damage that's what I'm
concerned about
no um the way they have it set up right
now
um it would not and then we've been at
home for a year and um hasn't had zero
issues in regards to well based on that
uh if I were you uh and I was I I knew
that there was no way it was going to
cause even more damage uh yeah I would
put it off as until you can cash flow it
yeah so here's the math on this Greg you
have six in the bank it's cost 34 that
puts you at a deficit of 28. let's say
you have seven months that means we have
to save four thousand dollars a month to
get there now you make 56 you get the
extra 350 we need to up the income ASAP
yes we need to decrease all expenses for
those seven months and we probably need
to look around and sell everything if
that means selling the cars and
downgrading in car for a season in order
to get to that 34 then it's worth it
because you don't have a way out of this
thing and I would never recommend you
jump into a HELOC or a second mortgage
or any of these options it's moving you
backwards it's going to put you guys in
a bind and you need to get this
emergency C fund loaded up ASAP because
this is a dangerous situation to get
into a very expensive property with no
money in the bank yeah and if your wife
can do remote work from home part-time
that's all going towards paying this off
everything has to be on the table
wishing you the best man this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from blinds.com find out
for yourself why they are the number one
online retailer of custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code Ramsay to get the
best deal today's question comes from
Colin in Wisconsin I'm 17 years old with
a lawn care business I'm making on
average 800 a week and currently have
about twenty two thousand dollars saved
I enjoy working for myself and think
that is what I want to do in the future
I'm wondering about any advice you have
for me trying to grow my business and
what should I be doing with my money I
don't want to just keep it in the bank I
want my money to be working for me but I
don't know the best way to do it well uh
George I will
pass this question over to you on on
what to be doing with the money I'll
I'll jump in here on the uh growing of
the business so fundamentally
the way you grow your business is
increasing the cost for your product or
service
or and maybe and or adding new services
or products right so you've got a
landscaping company and so you're doing
very very well it's long excuse me it's
a lawn care business but I would be
looking at Landscaping right so you know
could you add some services to if you've
got residential clients or professional
clients like a restaurant or something
depending on what he has I'm looking at
my existing client base and I'm going
okay if I'm cutting lawns
uh what are the margins for mulching
weeding you know other things like that
and if the margins are good
and they already know you and presumably
they're going to be doing that anyway
then that's the idea of adding a service
and so that brings in additional Revenue
but then you got to look at all right
I'm taking good care of my clients and
what is my annual bump you know I'm
going to look at the competition and I
want to be priced fairly but I don't
ever want to be the bottom price
um and so you're looking at those type
of strategies the other thing to be
considering is is if you're adding lawns
well there's only so much you can do you
are the face of the business so what is
the cost of adding Lawns meaning uh
let's say I add 10 more Lawns a month
and I'm still charging the same amount
we're just making this up you know but
I'm I'm charging a hundred dollars or
whatever uh Purl on
um if you add the Lawns then you have to
go okay I can't do the cutting and so
who's going to cut and so I'm now paying
someone an hourly wage so we take the
the the income
and then we minus the expenses of what
it's going to take to service this new
income and you start to begin to just
walk through this slowly you're 18 I
mean 17 you're doing a great job you
know you don't want to grow too fast but
you just look at what does it cost me to
expand and we're looking at time and
money equipment all of that and go okay
is that a good move to try to increase
my income thus grow the company but that
that's where you're going to go if you
stay in this business long term that's
how that's how it will go so you always
got a price in growth absolutely and
have a vision for where you want this
business to be do you want it to be the
biggest in town do you want to have a
team of 20 people or do you just like
doing it yourself and over time you may
get tired of that so you may need to go
hire one or two people now uh Ken
mentioned some great tips on growing the
business you can also look into some you
know lawn care is all about marketing
and it's all about word of mouth I go to
my neighbors I go to my neighborhood
Facebook group and I go hey who who cuts
a great lawn for a decent price yep
great they show up they do reliable work
uh you can do referral programs where
you go all right I'm going to give you
25 if you refer a new client over to me
so there's a lot of things you can do on
that Arena but you specifically asked
how do I make sure my money's working
for me well number one it doesn't sound
like you've gone into debt which I love
and so I want you to continue to grow
your business debt free I want you to
continue to live your personal life debt
free and you have 22 000 in the bank
that's a great emergency fund part of
that may become your retained earnings
for your business so have a separate
savings account for your business make
it official if you haven't already with
you know llc's and you can look into
what options make sense for what kind of
business you're running and then you're
gonna know I need to upgrade the
equipment once every few years I might
need to get the Zero Turn Mower and hire
a new person let me do all of that with
cash in the next year
lowers George I gotta tell you if I had
a yard that justified one of those
I'd get one totally you've seen those
dudes spin around on those things oh
yeah looks like a lot of fun it's a
great time so on the business side
there's that you can also on the
investing side you know put your savings
in high yield savings account you can
invest in a Roth IRA with your earned
income you can look at sep IRAs and solo
401K so those are for self-employed
folks which are a great option and so
start to look into all that but you're
17 man you get your whole life ahead of
you so grow slow like Ken said do it at
the speed of cash and I hope this thing
takes off yeah 20 years from now you
have an amazing I like his chances
that's a smart 17 year old we need more
of those all right we're going to the
phones Bentonville Arkansas is where we
head to next Shane joins us there Shane
welcome to the show
hey thanks guys what's going on I have a
date Segway into the next question here
oh great
um I have a small business small
construction business here in
Bentonville and
um I was wanting to see what should I be
making like what should I be profiting
for my business
are you talking about your salary or
from a just overall business standpoint
sure and overall as well of course I uh
it's my first year in business
um I've known the business for a while
the first year on my own uh and I'm
scared to take a salary oh you're not
even doing everything cash and are you
not pulling any salary right now
no no not for the whole year but I mean
I have a uh a savings account and a tax
account if you will so those might be
considered salary at the end of the year
but okay well how much profit have you
made so far
looking at what your gross revenue
versus your net profit
so we're right at around 40
um 40 if I don't calculate taxes that's
profit that's pretty good
have you talked to others in the
industry and done your homework to see
hey generally this is the number you
want to be at for construction because
every business is different some have
very little margins but high priced
products and some have crazy margins
yeah it's a It's actually an East Market
it's uh it's it's construction but I I
installed tubing for pressure washer
systems so I don't that's about how much
as it gets yeah and it's working man so
what is your top line revenue for so far
um so this year I'm looking at making
right at 100.
um I mean that's what the that's what
the 1099 will be so listen I you should
be very happy with 40 profit that is a
tremendous margin right there it really
is
I mean that's that's really good what's
your overhead currently
so my overhead uh can let it consist of
or what the price is what does it
consist of
um so I just work out of my home like I
have a home office if you will but the
uh a lot of its flights rental car
because it's all over the country and uh
yeah are those expenses passed on to uh
the client in addition to the work or do
you have to absorb that within your
pricing
that's what I absorb that's that's what
makes up that you know 50 to 60 percent
got it
um and how much money you probably
already asked this I was doing a little
research while you're but what did you
clear last year actual net profit
well this will be my first year dude oh
I'm sorry that's right what do you think
your net profit's gonna be at the end of
the year
um well that's that's what I'm hoping at
that 40 of course I need to no no no I
get the percentage what's the actual
number what do you think the number is
going to be in the bank net profit
oh that'd be four forty thousand okay so
you brought in a hundred or or so you
said
yeah okay it may be or so yeah so you
don't have a lot of you don't have do
you have a bunch of equipment and other
things like that I mean what what are
you having to service outside of just
your time
um so again a lot of that's just the the
travel cost if you will so you don't
have equipment costs and things like
that
no no I got like a bag of tools so if uh
you know 50 pounds of tools I love that
I I think you should be paying yourself
at the end of this year I wouldn't keep
living off the savings I mean you know
you you're it sounds like your base is
now 40 000 and we work on upping that
every year that's right by increasing
what we're charging and trying to
decrease all the costs and maybe you end
up hiring someone could you do that
yeah I mean you know like down the road
from there and take a lot more jobs for
sure yeah yeah the ease into that one
but I think in in this first year you're
trying to figure out where can I cut on
some of those expenses but some of those
are kind of fixed and related to I gotta
get there and do that stay at the hotel
and all that but I love it you got a
really nice profit margin and I would be
thrilled with that in year one yeah
Shane hang on the line we're going to
send you a copy of Dave's book entree
leadership it's his playbook for how he
built this business from a card table in
his living room to what it is today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
First Corinthians 8 2. anyone who claims
to know all the answers doesn't really
know very much
Timeless biblical wisdom from what I
assume is the message that was very hip
you could tweet that out all right Dick
Van Dyke once said just knowing you
don't have the answers is a recipe for
humility openness acceptance forgiveness
and an eagerness to learn and those are
all good things
wow I don't I don't know if I feel
confident giving uh advice here we don't
have all the answers but what we do in
the show is we try our best Ken yeah so
we don't have the answers but we can't
give you hope we'll give you some
homework and some sense that's what we
do I love it well let's see if we can do
that for our friend Christine she's on
the line in Philadelphia Christine how
you doing
hi guys I'm doing good thanks for taking
my call sure how can we help
so my husband and I are completely debt
free and we are currently renting uh
because we're a military and government
family so we really don't know where
we'll live because we usually uproot
every like three to four years we have a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
our high yield savings account right now
and we're wondering um if we should keep
that there just in the event that we
might buy in the next couple years or if
we should do something different with
that
well it sounds like you guys are doing
it exactly how I would do it
so I love that you're you're
renting with patients going hey we don't
know what the future is going to hold
we're uprooted every three years and
especially in military communities the
housing market can be a very different
scene because of how much supply and
demand is fluctuating
so yeah what does the future look like
for you guys is it just continuing to
move every three years for the
foreseeable future
this year in the fall however
even with those new orders it'll be
another you know three years but
um I just don't feel like that's long
enough to buy a home and get settled and
everything it just feel like you know
three years goes by so fast it just and
he might be staying in for 20 years
um his whole 20 he's 16 now but he's not
sure so I guess until we know that or
not I I just don't know what we should
do with that I would continue to just
stack on top of that and if you can save
up you know what's the what's the
household income
um I'm 100 and he's 45 so 145. oh
incredible so making 145 how much can
you add to it every year could you add
50 75k even
yeah probably
um we're pretty fortunate where I can
get like a lot of overtime like when he
goes and deploys I just do nothing but
overtime since we don't have children
right now so wow that is awesome you
guys are incredible yeah I agree with
George because depending on which
direction you guys go how long he's
going to be in the service
I mean you're stacking things up to
where you're going to be in really great
position to settle down and right now
it's I it's difficult I've known a lot
of military families I grew up in the
Hampton Roads area of Virginia heavy
military you know uh population and so
had a lot of and that moving every two
to three years is exhausting and trying
to sell a house buy a house every two or
three years is that's a lot yeah so I
think Christine it would be a cool goal
to say how cool would it be if we could
pay cash for a home down the line and
that might be five years from now yeah
because we don't know what's going to
happen and if you do buy a home and you
have enough money to buy cash you could
buy cash and then sell it four years
down the line and that home you know
history has shown us will appreciate in
value and so the only thing you have to
deal with is you know fees and a
headache but again in these military
communities I would work with a realtor
to go is this a good buy historically am
I going to lose money on this deal after
fees by buying in this area and selling
three years later
okay and
if we plan on renting if he stays in the
military for the 20 years and just we
just do nothing but rent whether it be
um
wise to maybe buy a rental instead with
that money and let that appreciate
that's an option if you can buy a rental
with cash and you guys just want to
continue renting because life's kind of
in flux that's a great option now the
problem is you're going to be a long
distance landlord which I would not
recommend and so you buy a spot where
you live and then all of a sudden three
years later you move and I'd never
recommend a long-term landlord situation
so I would uh do your homework on that
one to see is it worth doing it for you
know four years while we're in this
location to buy a rental property and
rent it out
okay yeah that makes sense I appreciate
you guys's advice yeah absolutely thank
you for the call and if you were going
to invest that money long term you knew
it was going to be a five plus year play
I would contact one of our smartvestor
pros and look into you know opening a
brokerage account where you might be
able to make seven eight nine ten
percent on that money uh instead of the
two percent in a high yield savings
account and and you know I I didn't
mention this because I I don't know the
full situation not talking to your
husband but one of the conversations I
think is worth having over a date night
is you know what would make you stay in
for the full 20 years what would what
would make you get out you know are you
scared of it I know a lot of men and
women in the military in fact we've got
a lot of these calls on the Ken Coleman
show over the years going hey I'm
getting out in two or three years and
Ken I'm scared that I'm not going to be
able to do anything and there's a
there's a real thing here
um in fact we did a you know last year
we did a full hour on Fox businesses
that's right I went up to New York and
sat with Charles Payne and the name of
the entire hour as a special called from
military to the marketplace and I'm just
bringing this up because a lot of men
and women in the military feel like it's
my only option because that's all I've
done so far and I've got experience in
the military and I don't think it'll
translate to the marketplace and we had
several military veterans on that show
that day who you know agreed with me and
they were basically saying we've done it
you've been trained by one of the
greatest organizations in the world you
are extremely relevant I bring all this
up Christine and George to say
that you know you might be able to adapt
your lifestyle tremendously if he goes
all right next time I'm up for re-upping
if I think ahead and go wait a second
what would I do what could I do what do
I want to do and if you want to stay in
the service awesome love our men and
women uh in the military think thank God
for them every day
but that's something to think about
because now they're in a really good
financial situation with what she makes
and what they've saved and then if he
comes out and doubles his salary in the
private sector which is not unreasonable
to believe now it's a game changer
Christine so I I won't at least put that
idea out there no that's a great call
out and uh please thank him for his
service Christine that's incredible uh
Patrick joins us up next in La Crosse
Wisconsin Patrick welcome to the show
hello thanks for having me
um my question is that I'm at 45 000 in
college debt and I will be going into my
senior year in the spring semester
and I'm wondering if I should take out
another twenty thousand dollars in debt
and get my degree or pay it off before
going again
well if the options are going further
into debt and digging this hole even
deeper versus what's the other option
pausing
the other option would just be to pause
and then
find a job I don't really have any
skills to get a good job to pay it off
fast what were you studying
psychology why were you studying that
I really think too much when I jumped
into it but uh I suppose I'd be a
counselor okay I can just tell you right
now I would press pause on the final
year and the twenty thousand dollars you
don't have it
not only do you not have it you
shouldn't borrow it and then the third
option is I'm not even sure you're going
to use it and now if we can get clear
that we we do need the degree then we'd
finish it but this idea that well I'm
three years in or I'm so many years in
this fallacy yeah like yeah that's fancy
language you want to explain cost
fallacy yeah when you dig so much time
and effort and money into something you
go well I'm too deep in it now so I got
to stay here I got to continue down this
path that I know is going nowhere and so
that's what we're talking about here and
I know you feel like you paid a stupid
tax and you go man that was a mistake
but don't continue this yeah Patrick
here's what I'm saying
you need to know that you know that you
know that you know that you want to be a
counselor
thus you do need the psychology degree
the undergrad but then there's more
schooling if you don't know that and you
just kind of jumped into it it's okay
you're not a loser you're not a flake
you do have skills you can work in this
job economy right now it's a really
attractive job economy I would
absolutely press pause go work but not
just work
work to pay off the current debt and
then while you're doing that you are
getting ahead you're not a loser you're
not falling behind and let's get really
really clear on what you want to do in
fact George right now we've got the get
clear assessment on sale for only ten
dollars that's right ramsayslutions.com
I want to give that to you so hang on
the line we're going to give you the get
clear assessment it's a 20-minute
assessment and it's going to give you
real clarity about where you actually do
want to go with your professional life
so hang on good stuff thank you Ken and
thank you to all the folks in the booth
Austin and Ben and James and Andrew and
Zach for keeping the show afloat today
and you America thank you so much for
listening until next time spend wisely
save intentionally and give generously
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]